I'm fine I'm fine ready to go yep sure
em yeah all set you're a big TV fan
right I mean besides the fact that
you're on a TV show mm-hmm do you watch
a lot of TV on the weekends that's based
on my antisocial behavior yes it's one
of the few things I can do just sit
around like in a v-neck t-shirt with a
beer and watch TV that's right pretty
much than else and nothing else yeah
good for you all right
well I bring this up for very good
reason Andy I'm excited tonight folks
you've probably heard they keep saying
that we're coming up on a time when
we'll have 500 channels there's the
information superhighway
and I'm really excited because I've been
waiting for this you know I still have
one of those sets that has like six or
seven channels and that's it well I'm
excited because folks finally NBC and
General Electric coughed up the money to
buy one of those big satellite dishes
and they put it right on the top of
Rockefeller Center and that means right
now on this show I can get literally
hundreds of channels I have a catalog
right here we can get hundreds of
channels now which is really neat I mean
it means I have to watch TV here at the
show you know but besides that this is
great we can literally see like all
those channels you've been hearing so
much about and I thought it might be fun
if you guys are up for it
let's tonight take a look at my new TV
system with the satellite dish and look
at some
[Applause]
it really is amazing it really is
amazing a different kind of stuff I can
get like for example I mean there's some
of the basic stuff still headline is
president Boris Johnson which is really
useful you want to come up with jokes
you look at what's on the news she gets
some of the basic stuff you all forget I
get Fox sister I get Fox's icebox all
right that's Fox actually this is the
news this is the Fox News yeah yeah I
don't I don't really mind it at all you
also get a look at this right here
I get the according to this I get the
Weather Channel oh this is great yeah
this is really helpful
watching per hours you can watch it it
tells you the weather all over the
country any time of day really a cool
thing and sort of in a related thing
right here I get look at this so I get
the humidity Channel I don't know just
you know it's uncomfortable to walk look
for some reason yeah no you think he
would have worn a lighter to for sure
but still it's how far and you get to
see this stuff which is really fun I
would watch this for hours I don't know
about you
now let's see what this this year this
is
[Music]
not quite sure what this is actually
this is uh oh wait no that's our men
that's the year 2000 a foreign language
no I've heard about this they actually
do a Cuban version of our show ah yeah
this is a Cuban version this is the this
is the Cuban late night and from cocoon
Sharon Stone Adriana Velasquez gets all
the good gasps I really don't understand
it all right well look at this we also
get here's one I've heard about take a
look at this right here
now this is actually a real thing I've
heard about this is the fishtank Channel
all right you just look at this it's
very calming it's supposed to relax you
just to see fish kind of swimming around
in a fish tank drives an ADD nut yeah
this is a real thing and they also have
they have another version of this take a
look at this okay this is the this is
the screaming fish tank channel I like
this one much better it's not quite as
relaxing yeah all right now something
about the idea of panicky fish yeah I'm
not crazy about it either look at this
one here hold on just a sec this is one
I want to take a look at this is a
suggestions for where you might have
left your keys channel take a look at
this on your dresser in the bedroom
and coffee table the table in the
hallway did you check the cushions of
the couch the couch question let's make
thought of it this is really useful this
could help people floor is clearly how
he's talking about oh here's one this
one is kind of actually related to our
show let's take a look at this one right
here yeah this is the interesting wood
surface
actually we're thinking I could get a
bag of Doritos watch this for like nine
hours all right this one right here
you're gonna like this one
this is the swearword Kronk that we're
gonna crunk you now with regards to the
need for a search warrant - okay don't
get mad have you checked your pockets we
sort of seen this one alright this is a
Korean news report actually and I guess
it's on some kind of awful murder a
terrible crime I guess was committed try
this one
really you sure yeah I don't speak
Korean to you why should we watch that
okay all right all right
we now return with love on fire on the
badly lit Channel
[Applause]
[Music]
Sara if you think third-degree burns
over 80% of your face are gonna make me
love you any less you're wrong
you don't understand Jeffery and you
wake up to this face every morning kiss
it every morning I don't know it's the
ones gonna catch on no you know I think
we should just babble it channel not a
great idea now here's one it's called
Roker - Roker let's take a look at it
that that's exactly what I'm trying to
get at yeah I've talked to a lot of
people about you and they all tell me
you're a genius how do you respond to
that out well it's true hey that's great
al thanks for opening up and we'll be
right back you gotta get one all right
now let's see what else is on Omega we
we only have time to look at one more
but there's one that I really am curious
about Andy it's called the death ray
Channel Wow and you know it's one of
those things I have no idea what it
could be what's just let's just check it
out right now and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
put stop now alright folks turn to stop
playing with our TV you wanna take a
quick break when we come back
David Barras is going to be here